[Musica]
ciao sono unità ma due vengo dalla
striscia di gaza sono nato e negli
emirati
dopo dopo nove anni sono andato a vivere
a casa perché la mia famiglia sono da
casa a casa una città un po somiglia ma
quando qualcuno conosce macondo come
città infatti ma quando una città non
esiste una città immaginato il scrittore
del libro di cento anni di solitudine
non esiste ma esiste nella sua testa
esiste con un altro nome casa che è
sofferto questa città isolata dal mondo
sofferta molto con le guerre con
problemi di politica di religione di
religione ecco la mia storia voglio
parlare 20 21 in 15 minuti
parlare di 20 giorni di 20 mesi di
solitudine dentro la mia camera tre
metri per tre
perché successo un giorno novembre 2013
19 che stavo con altri ragazzi un posto
pubblico
diciamo parlavamo pensavamo di fare una
qualcosa per la cultura per i ragazzi
attiviamo un po la situazione non
possiamo fare così non posso io come
donna sta stare con con altri ragazzi
maschi un post pubblico e anche senza
velo ero molto rebella infatti il
miliziani di hamas
il nostro nostro governo in casa sono
venuto mi hanno portato nella prigione
mi hanno picchiato mi hanno fatto tutto
quello che pensate anche di più per otto
giorni andavo tornavo stavo nella
prigione quella del mio babbo per uscire
per per finire questa cosa per finire
questo brutto sogno dovuto fermare per
un documento ma tornato dentro la mia
camera la mia camera tre metri per tre
dentro la mia camera c'è una finestra
piccola con mi ricordo che c'era il mio
armadio che era una scala che fatto come
come o armadio la mia macchina foto per
fotografare e ruota ci avevo ci avevo
delle cose non esiste in una camera di
una ragazza sono diventati la mia mi la
mia mice dopo allora sono entrato dentro
lame camera cosa voglio fare
non c'è non c'è niente da fare o prendo
quella strada che faccio quello che loro
vogliano di vinto un'altra persona per
loro
divento matta e perché dentro casa o con
me stessa sono una persona di cuore sono
un'altra proprio di fuori per tutto il
giorno se vogliono lavorare o voglio
vedere la gente ha detto
[Musica]
non c'è niente da fare sono stato dentro
la mia camera all'inizio qualsiasi
persona che vuole stare dentro una
camera non voglio dire per un mese ma
metti metti una settimana diventa matto
una cosa che non potete immaginare per
capire bisogna fare così
meglio non farlo comunque il primo il
primo mese sono stato malissimo volevo
morire sono questa idea che ci avevo
volevo morire
pensavo il modo di morire come posso
morire posso fare così non posso fare
così un giorno la mia mamma tornata dal
mercato con un po di verdure mi aveva
visto nella terra come sempre nella
terra nell'angolo piangevo come sempre
visto che sto così allora mi aveva detto
tieni questi cipolle questo verdure puoi
aiutarmi invece di stare ho detto va
bene ma guardate un po
non lo so non lo so cosa c'era nella mia
testa non pensavo di niente io non
volevo niente dal mondo io volevo morire
basta non pensavo di farvi un progetto
non pensavo da trasformare le cose
brutta farla buona come prima pensavo
come facevo da per sempre perché tutta
la mia energia andata non non avevo più
energia
non posso fare niente niente allora e
quella idea proprio lasciata via via
allora preso questi queste verdure dopo
guardato hanno come sempre come come
come sempre che sono artista e ma sono
sempre le cose vedo vedo sempre
le cose come tipo se voglio guardare una
faccia diciamo una una faccia e guardo
la guardo il frame e quello le più bello
e con centro anche nella faccia
qualsiasi cosa allora ho guardato così a
posso fare così mettere questo qui
quello qui ho fatto la foto dopo non
voglio fare una posizione ha fatto
questa posizione è stato per due ore
così tre ore
lavoravo per questa foto fino alla fine
non capivo perché hai fatto questa
posizione perché piangeva perché facevo
così non sapevo sapevo che voglio fare
questa foto io comunque scoperto dopo
dopo quando finito tutto il progetto ho
capito perché piange perché ha fatto
questa posizione ma in quel momento non
capivo allora fatto questa foto dopo due
ore la mia mamma tornata pensava che la
tutte le sue bolle sono trovato nel
piatto questa si è poi fatto tanto
problema come ma non c'è problema allora
pubblicato questa foto su internet un
sito tipo facebook ma per fotografi
mondiale questo costo è scritto sotto
che nella città che che non c'è più ho
finito l'amore io provo nella mia camera
a tre metri per tre
e fa fare questo mondo diciamo e dopo la
gente mi hanno scritto tutti bello
quintino ma nessuno sapeva cosa faccio
perché fatto questa foto co solo che gli
piacevano
e le foto piano piano fatto un'altra
l'altro mentre facevo la foto mi aveva
chiamato diciamo il manager di si sia
chiesto di fare una mostra a gerusalemme
fatto la mostra gerusalemme erano 14
foto ancora sono adesso 25 foto mi aveva
chiesto di fare la mostra è fatto la
mostra sicuramente fatto la mostra ero
dentro la mia camera
e questo dopo un anno 4 mesi quasi da
quel giorno non voglio dire che cambiato
la mia vita ma piano piano stava
cambiando la mia vita è perché new york
times scritto la mia storia
sulla prima pagina dagli altri e tante
altre i giornali hanno scritto di me una
di quelle era al corriere della sera
e qui cominciata un'altra storia che
multi grimano terme con molti catini
terme
mi hanno invitato per fare una mostra
multi catini e l'altra montegrimano
fatto la mostra o montecatini e multipli
umano ma questa volta ero qui che vedevo
la mia mostra per la prima volta e quel
giorno ho capito cosa vuol dire quella
foto la prima foto perché una dico una
di quelli che sono venute per vedere la
mostra mi aveva chiesto ma chi è la
prima foto che l'hai fatto e ho girato
così è perché non mi ricordavo perché
facevo prendevo anche un mese per fare
una foto perché aspettavo la luce giusta
di venire dalla finestra studiavo il
colore studiavo l'ombra studiavo la
posizione
studiavo tutto ci aveva avuto il tempo
24 ore al giorno per fortuna c'era il
ministro della cultura di san marino a
montegrimano per vedere
mia mostra e aveva chiesto di venire
visitari stamani marino e hanno fatto
una riunione in questa riunione avranno
chiesto se mi piacerebbe fare un diciamo
un workshop l'università di san marino
certo da qui con cambiato la mia vita
anche una cosa strana che san marino la
città della libertà che non lo so se era
per caso o o c'era qualcosa di york
ordini dalla mia camera dalla prigione
fino san marino la città della libertà
diciamo e da qui trovato provato tutto
trovato l'amore la libertà in merito
grazie ancora la mia mostra sta girando
al mondo new york andata a new york
sicuramente san marino in italia tante
tante città in italia magari all'inizio
per me era difficile parlare della mia
storia perché io già dentro dentro la
solitudine dimenticato quello che che
c'era perché occupavo il mio tempo di
fare tante altre cose
ma e qui c'era bisogno se vedi che c'era
bisogno di parlare della mia storia non
per me magari tante volta sentite mi
sento agitata miss e non mi senta
agitata perché parlo parlo da tanta
gente
all'inizio non mai citata perché questa
storia mi fa male molto quando quando
quando ho bisogno di parlare di questa
storia perché pesante molto ma nello
stesso tempo spero che la mia storia
arriva per altre ragazze che capiscono
cosa vuol dire non sono della libertà
tutto quello che ci avete tante altre
persone non sanno chi e 2 milioni
persone a casa non possono avere quello
che che ci avete come ragazzi allora
finito
[Applauso]
[Musica]